you can watch him but Mike's with Dave
Attell at the morongo casino resort and
Harrah's Resort this very weekend you
can also watch his new half-hour comedy
series historical roasts on Netflix he's
one of the most loved people in this
town and his profession not only because
he's funny because he is just an awesome
person great rich Jeffrey Ross good
intro you know what man I still get paid
top dollar for that in certain sections
that row is foreplay you understand like
like when I hear that everything starts
happening for me right now
like I wish I could rip this mic out of
the thing and walk around and work the
room you know what it's possible to work
snap the football you snap the football
- David tell Jeff lift Schultz - is that
your I was a center on the Jonathan
Dayton Regional High School Bulldogs in
Springfield New Jersey never won a game
four years and we got the video right
there there it is of you and you changed
you got down there down there and it's
like riding a bike you just not that
thing to me and tell couldn't even
believe it look at that was waiting on
talent very hidden talent my friend
historical roasts is fantastic and I
will explain why
Thank You bun cuz your your roasted you
know what a big fan of roasts I am rich
has been for his fans the rich has been
supported rich has been talking about
the roasts like sporting events since I
met him because they are events they are
events it is a competition between the
comedian's on stage against each other
and then against the the person who's
being roasted I grew up on the old Dean
Martin Rose I'm an old-school guy I know
you are to your your loved
loba the Buddy Hackett and Don Rickles
or people very near and dear to your
heart you can be you knew them you're
okay this under his show in a lot of
ways is an homage to those Dean Martin
Russ
well the interesting part about it is is
you're roasting historical figures
obviously historical roasts so
historical figures you're roasting the
two that I saw the at the premiere and
Brock when you're gonna love this man
exactly love this if you haven't already
seen it has it's been available for
streaming now for a couple weeks
Abe Lincoln yeah and Freddie Mercury
right okay
so not only do you have the roasty being
a historical figure but the Roasters
you're the roastmaster general you're
you're dressed in the garb of this I
played the roastmaster general of the
Union Army roasting Abe Lincoln played
by Bob Saget and then as soon as Bob
said he was willing to play Abe Lincoln
I had a call John Stamos and say I need
a job Wilkes Booth and the chemistry
between them too is so phenomenal and
then we round it out with Harriet Tubman
played by yamaneika thought she was
amazing she stole the show as did
Natasha Leggero as Mary Todd Lincoln a
drug-addled Mary Todd Lincoln get up
there and the funny thing is is that not
only are the jokes at the expense of the
historical figure but they're at the
expense of the actor and actresses who
are playing this you kind of step a
couple times you step out and you make
it like a celebrity rose to mix with the
historical rose and then you learn you
actually learn a little bit of something
about the history yeah and it's
intelligent it's funny it's and the
audience is dressed also in the garb of
the era as well that was a part that was
something I wanted to do from my
childhood I used to dress up and go to
Rocky Horror Picture Show sure as a high
schooler and I thought I want my show to
be a party I want to throw a party for
Abe Lincoln and have the audience and
that way it's easier to get the wives if
I call up Saget and Stamos that I call
the wives separately I say come early
are our costumers gonna dress you up
yeah it's gonna be a party we're gonna
have fun and suddenly like they're all
like yeah alright we're all in and it
was it's it's so damn funny it really is
and it's worth it well I even tried to
give you a log line or a tag line for
historical roasts what what did Netflix
land on what does he landed on teaching
history a lesson teaching history lesson
to struggle mine was it's never too soon
and then you and then you add it it's
never too late either because some of
these people Cleopatra
it's never too soon and it's never too
late it's Britt look either way it's
just awesome it really so who are the
other ones that uh that are being
roasted
well we roasted uh Muhammad Ali on this
one okay and who were the ones who
roasted Muhammad Ali it was what we
called the goat roast
so although the greatest of all time in
their fields so Babe Ruth obviously
Bruce Lee
it was my idol as a black belt in
Taekwondo Vince Lee really inspired me
as a kid
yes and then of course Josh Homme II
from Queens of the Stone Age plays Elvis
and he just sings at the end there's a
lot of music in this show okay and Ali
was all he was great my opening joke
dolly Jaleel White
Muhammad Ali all right he kills it he
knows a lot about sports no I know he's
been on this show many times he really
he plays two characters on the show on
one episode he plays Ollie and then on
the roast of Martin Luther King Jaleel
plays Nelson Mandela and he got a
standing ovation he was so funny he's
such a talented guy he sits down in the
in the in the seat of Honor at the
Muhammad Ali roast yes and I'm wearing a
wig and I'm doing a hybrid
Jeff Ross Howard Cosell characters media
we go into like the classic alley
Billy Crystal thing where Jaleel as
ollie is grabbing for my toupee
and I'm just trying to stay in the
camera shot by just going and and and
Jaleel sits down and he's very in
character when you're watching and I say
you know this is amazing
we wanted to roast the greatest athlete
of all time but Serena Williams wasn't
available it was really good it was
really fun it's a party but it's also
educational I mean we go deep
we roast Anne Frank on the show oh man
now Wow no kidding that's right you told
me that but Wow
I forgot you told me that how did that
go it went very very well
you know what you complain once and
Frank is near and dear to my heart I
read her diary as a kid they all didn't
let me what my uncle Murray and the
greatest generation fought for during
World War two right and I didn't want to
roast people I don't love I love Anne
Frank right oh she gets she's up there
in the seat of Honor and let's face it
the whole thing kind of turned into a
Hitler roast Jon Lovitz plays FDR in the
lederhosen by the way I called Gilbert
up and said will you play Hitler and I
didn't even get solar out and he was
like yes yes it does no good I wanted to
keep her name and story alive more and
more my show isn't for people close to
her story it's for people who might not
remember or might get her confused with
Helen Keller or or never even know about
the Holocaust so it really goes out to
the 180 countries where Netflix I do
have to say a couple of times during the
premiere where we saw the two of them
and as you know we have three small
children so Sue's you know I do not
watch much television rather but we we
have a totally plan to watch the other
four now we did say to each other a
couple of times during the two like we
didn't know that like literally there
were a couple of facts like we did not
know Oh like an actual historical lesson
well you know and there's a show on
Netflix that we did watch with our kids
called who was uh-huh
which is a book about a bunch of books
about who was that these kids read about
who was Gandhi who was Abraham Lincoln
but it's real for kids like they
actually but they also have a lot of fun
with it for adults to me this is like
the who was for adults I guess it really
it really is I can't speak about it
enough and then when you you mentioned
the the Freddie Mercury Roast Seth Green
plays Chloe but in the full Ziggy
Stardust outfit
by the way hosta he left that on four
hours after the show well I've got some
good news for you Jeffrey Ross go ahead
Mike tell two folk fellow New Jersey
it--of Jeffrey Ross tell him what you
what you've done so last night I get to
vote for the Primetime Emmys I got one
of your categories so I took Kerry could
you imagine if my Rochelle
I mean I've a blinking one was for what
I didn't get to watch the whole thing
yeah but when I watched I was dying that
means so much yeah you know I you always
want to make people in the business and
conveniently and that means a lot when
that happens well bro rich has been
supporting the roasts forever he's
always calling me up with lines if I
have jokes I'm not sure about I can call
rich up and go does this make sense
especially if I'm roasting an athlete I
go rich I go where's the line is this
okay yeah you're really good with that
well you know what because I'm a huge
fan of yours just a huge fan of the
concept of roasts because in our day and
age there is somewhat of a more of a
lack of sense of humor of certainly
poking fun of yourself laughing at the
world about serious things and you know
having serious people get roasted is
just a fun thing to watch and see the
shatner roast that you invited me to
when he strolled in on when he rode in
on a horse William Shatner rode into the
roast
horse okay and you could kind of see him
stroll past the table Susie and I are
sitting at and then George Takei gets up
there line of the second line of the
century this is a bill I've been waiting
to say this to you I've been waiting to
say this to you forever and he says the
real word it goes F you and the horse
you rode in on by the way that night is
when Betty White began her major
comeback rushed it at that rose and
that's when the Facebook the Facebook
campaigns to get her to host him from
that night at that roast
you're right you're right see I'm uh I'm
a historian roaster is a historical fact
you might not guess Jeff everybody white
is so old the color white was named
after her watching you do only roast the
ones you love that is a true story
though
yeah that is because that's the old so
does that mean you love alec baldwin cuz
that's the new some of my favorite
movies okay so now when you do you
personally reach out to Alec Baldwin to
make something like this happen how does
this case I did not but sometimes I do
okay so in this case Comedy Central
hooked it up without okay I've been
talking them for a while and of course
I'm I'm in all those conversations sure
one of the producers of the show right
so you give a check mark through certain
lists of people and then they reach out
to talk about who we target like that's
the guy I want now I take it who has
thick skin sure who's got something
going on and and like who they can draw
like with Alec
he's been connected to so many great
film stars and TV stars I think he's
gonna have an incredible dais and I
can't say too much yet but I think this
is gonna go down as a very very
memorable room okay so you already have
some names that you can't mention right
now that I think that will fill out the
dais huh I mean Alec Baldwin think about
all the great people whose work no
question about it and I saw his
comedians in cars getting coffee with
wit Seinfeld right he's one of the
funniest ones that they they had very
clever guy for a good-looking guy he's
very funny rare good-looking people
can't he wants to hear a good-looking
guys self-deprecating I can't meet a
girl what are you gonna Brad Pitt's
never gonna do stand-up guys like look
like me do stand-up you're a very
handsome man thank you I do want to say
this Jeff I've known you now as I just
mentioned it's coming up on 20 years
well the the ladies that you have dated
and been around you don't seem to be
hurting Jeffery you can make a woman
laugh at herself you can make her do
anything
it's all in the roast mind that's like a
Jedi trick or something like that sort
of thing yes oh my gosh put that on a
bumper sticker these are the jokes
you're hearing yeah you know uh you know
that part of comedy is good you are
you're absolutely killing it right now
there's no doubt about that
right am I allowed to wish you an early
happy birthday what's your happy
birthday I love you so much
right right back at you Jeff Ross I
appreciate that immensely you're the
best so you're doing bumping mics with
David tell my other Netflix show bumping
mics with Dave Attell we did three
episodes late last year on Netflix and
we decided to do some casino dates Dave
will only do casinos because they let
them smoke in the elevator and
everywhere else morongo tomorrow all
right out here in California and then
now down near San Diego will be at
Harrah's and then you got a rose I
didn't get a rose battle coming up yeah
June 21st will be up a cluster fest in
San Francisco that's a fun comedy now
you you had I saw he was at your
premiere for historical roasts and also
in the roast battle Blake Griffin yeah
he's really good at this Lake is a
comedian like it's crazy you would call
it like you'd use these think he has the
chops imagine if I could also dunk to do
that it's great it's not fair he's funny
he's that legit and I roast battled him
I saw that that Comedy Central you can
look it up he murdered like he worked
really hard on it and and he challenged
me on Twitter and I accept it and we did
it and it went and a Jeselnik and Pete
Davidson at Nikki Glaser were the judges
and they tied and Pete gave me the win
but it was close
no kidding what is what is whose Fred
Willard in an upcoming historical
Willard plays God Frank Rose who
basically gets for clamped and
overwhelmed and that's how that's how
and spoil it too much but oh my god the
people on this show Fred Willard we
mentioned Saget
Stamos James Adomian plays Freddie
Mercury Nikki Glaser plays Kurt Cobain
she was out of control as Kurt Cobain it
was really really fun and and and the
mercury Rose was fantastic it's really a
party mercury III grew up not knowing
much about Freddy I worshiped his music
right and his sexuality and those things
never meant anything to me I didn't care
about any of that he to me he was just a
grown man who sang opera wearing a
onesie and you know Queens one of my
favorites
I thought that would be a good one to
honor well I I hope you get to do more
it might be a good historical road would
be your favorite oh gosh Wow who would
be my favorite a historical where you
would have to be there would gandhi be
you're gonna be a great one Gandhi would
be a good one I think it's about time it
needs to be taken down a peg
go for it Chris you for JFK JFK that's a
good one
yeah he needs a roast like he needs
another holt never mind it's never too
soon or too late never too soon never
too late there you go before I let you
go Jeff um you know a couple people in
the back of wondered to me how many how
many planks you have to break to be a
black belt how many did you have to
desert Lisette is an actual metric here
I don't look there's a number but I
think it's when the pressures on when
the tourneys happen when the tests
happened well break one right now if you
need do we have one anywhere can we get
a plank for this not a plank right I
mean why not that's a 2-byte that 2x4
that's right no what is it now you got
me I have no idea let me see it
standard plywood I'm guessing you're
ready to cancel my show of morongo
tomorrow I have a broken hand you
haven't taken it off and you should be
amazing your filter could break the
proper I can break this
in the plus-one take a seat we're gonna
get you've now earned another television
only segment Jeffrey wrong man take
blanket - OH
ever broken aboard in 20 years football
every single time Jeff comes on he's
gonna have to do something in two
decades Jeffrey Ross on Twitter at the
real Jeffrey Ross on Instagram
historical roast is a must
stream for you right here right now love
you man thanks for coming I love you
that's Jeffrey Ross right here on the
show when we come back your phone calls
at 844 204 rich but one week return for
the TV audience Jeffrey Ross black belt
he will be I will be the son say that's
next on the Rich Eisen show alright
we're back with Jeff Ross black belt
he'll either be bumping mics or bumping
fresh-made casts with Dave Attell I
don't know what kind of wood this is and
I haven't done this since I was 12
okay do you want to do give it a try if
you think you can do it but this is what
I learned at the house of empty hands in
Newark New Jersey the house of empty
hands is 70 ok very good go part of the
cut part of it is using the hammer of
your hand and I'm not looking at the
wood I'm looking below the wood ok cuz I
gotta see right through it
did it break hold on hold it down dude
that's better yeah be good Chris hold on
the other side Chris all right it's
going hold it pull it pull it out a
little bit more for the inners is on the
box you don't even have any unity music
from Karate Kid if he gets it worried
uh-oh here we go
forget it I really thought I can do it
rich I really thought I could do it okay
Jeff we still love you for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app